En este video vamos a hablar de funciones lineales
y relaciones proporcionales. Iniciemos recordando
la noción de razón entre dos magnitudes. La razón
es una comparación entre dos magnitudes que se
expresan mediante un cociente, suele expresarse
como una fracción o colocando dos puntos entre
las dos magnitudes. Por ejemplo, si tenemos las
magnitudes a y b, la razón entre esas magnitudes
la podemos expresar de la siguiente manera: a / b
o a : b; cualquiera de las dos formas se lee: a es
a b, a es a b. Al cociente le llamamos razón y al
resultado de la división le llamamos valor de la
razón. En este caso a c le podemos llamar valor de
la razón. Veamos un ejemplo: 8 / 4, y lo podemos
escribir como cociente o con dos puntos, 8 : 4.
Ahora vamos a definir lo que es una proporción.
Una proporción es la igualdad de dos razones;
por ejemplo, si tenemos a / b y la razón c / d,
podemos expresar una proporción como sigue, y se
lee: a / b = c / d, y también lo podemos expresar
con dos puntos: a : b, y para expresar "como"
escribimos dos puntos dos veces: :: c : d, c dos
puntos d. Lo que esto nos indica es que esta
razón es igual a esta otra razón. Vamos a ver
estas expresiones con números enteros. Digamos que
tenemos la razón 20 / 10 y 40 / 20. ¿Cómo sabemos
que estas razones son iguales? Calculamos el valor
de estas divisiones: 20 / 10 = 2, ponemos el signo
igual, y 40 / 20 = 2. Vemos que la proporción es
correcta porque existe una igualdad de valores
entre las dos razones. Otro ejemplo sería 24 / 3
como 40 / 5. ¿Cómo sabemos si realmente existe una
igualdad entre esas dos razones? Bueno, podemos
sacar el valor de cada razón. En este caso,
24 / 3 = 8, y ponemos el signo igual, y 40 /
5 = 8; las dos razones tienen el mismo valor,
por lo tanto la proporción es correcta. Ahora nos
presentan el siguiente problema. En una feria se
ofrecen libros de diversos precios en oferta. Juan
visitó la librería "Nuevo mundo" y compró un libro
de cuentos cuyo precio original era de 8 dólares,
pero pagó 4 dólares con el descuento; María,
en la librería "La cultura", compró un libro de
arte cuyo precio original era de 16 dólares, pero
pagó 12 dólares con el descuento. Si cada librería
guarda una proporción en sus propios descuentos,
¿cuál sería el precio con descuento de un libro
de cocina cuyo precio original es de 40 dólares
en ambas? Vamos a revisar la información que nos
dan. En la librería "Nuevo mundo", Juan compró un
libro de cuentos, y el precio sin descuento era
de 8 dólares y con descuento era de 4 dólares;
y María, en la librería "La cultura", compró un
libro de arte: sin descuento el libro costaba 16
dólares y con descuento lo compró en 12 dólares.
Vamos a resolver este problema mediante el uso de
funciones lineales. Una función lineal es una
relación entre dos variables: la variable x se
llama variable independiente; f(x) indica evaluar
la función f con el valor de x; y el resultado lo
podemos llamar y, que es la variable dependiente,
ya que su valor depende del valor del cálculo de
la función a partir de x; a es la pendiente. Si
no recuerdas las funciones lineales, su forma
general y sus partes, te invito a que revises los
videos que tenemos sobre este tema. En el caso de
nuestro problema: a, la pendiente, será el valor
del descuento que se ha asignado en cada librería,
y, o f(x), es el precio con descuento, y x es
el precio del libro sin descuento. Calculemos
el descuento de la librería "Nuevo mundo": f(x),
que es el precio con descuento, es igual a 4 y x,
es decir el precio sin descuento, es igual a 8.
Si despejamos la pendiente a, o el descuento,
será igual a f(x) / x, es lo mismo que el precio
con descuento entre el precio sin descuento,
es decir: 4 / 8, 4 / 8 = 0.5, de modo que el
descuento en la librería "Nuevo mundo" es igual
a 0.5, es decir, sólo se cobra el 0.5 o la mitad
del valor original del libro. Podemos pensar la
pendiente de la función lineal como la razón
de cambio de la variable dependiente a partir
del valor de x. Hagamos una tabla para anotar los
valores de nuestra función lineal para la librería
"Nuevo mundo". En esta columna tenemos el valor de
x, que es igual al precio del libro sin descuento,
y en esta columna tenemos el valor de la función,
que en este caso es igual a 0.5 x. El precio del
libro de cuentos sin descuento es igual a 8 y
el precio del libro con descuento es igual a
8 * 0.5 = 4. Ahora tenemos el precio del libro
de cocina: sin descuento, es igual a 40, y en
este caso el valor de la función, o el precio del
libro de cocina con el descuento de la librería
"Nuevo mundo", es igual a 40 * 0.5 = 20 dólares,
el precio con descuento del libro de cocina en la
librería "Nuevo mundo" es de 20 dólares. Como el
descuento en la librería "Nuevo mundo" se aplica
en la misma proporción para todos sus libros,
podemos comprobar esta proporción mediante el
uso de razones que mencionamos al principio. En
este caso, podemos escribir que 8 / 4 = 40 / 20;
si dividimos 8 / 4 el resultado es igual a 2, y
dividimos 40 / 20 y el resultado es igual a 2:
2 es igual a 2. Calculemos el descuento de la
librería "La cultura": g(x), que es el precio
con descuento, es igual a 12, y x, es decir el
precio sin descuento, es igual a 16. Como ya vimos
anteriormente, el valor del descuento es igual a
g(x) / x, es lo mismo que el precio con descuento
entre el precio sin descuento, es decir: 12 / 16,
12 / 16 = 0.75, de modo que la proporción que se
paga del precio original es de 0.75, es decir,
sólo se cobra el 0.75 del valor original del
libro, que representa un descuento del 25%. Ahora
hagamos la tabla para la librería "La cultura":
en esta columna tenemos el valor de x, que es
igual al precio del libro sin descuento, y en esta
columna tenemos el valor de la función, que en
este caso es igual a 0.75 x; el precio del libro
de arte sin descuento es igual a 16 y el precio
del libro con descuento es igual a 16 * 0.75, que
es igual a 12; ahora tenemos el precio del libro
de cocina sin descuento, que es igual a 40, y en
este caso el valor de la función, o el precio del
libro de cocina con el descuento de la librería
"La cultura", es igual a 40 * 0.75, que es igual
a 30 dólares: el precio con descuento del libro
de cocina en la librería "La cultura" es de 30
dólares. Ahora que tenemos las funciones lineales
de descuento para cada una de las librerías,
¿cuánto pagaría Juan si comprara un libro de
18 dólares en la librería "Nuevo mundo"? Vamos a
anotar nuestros datos en la tabla: x = 18 y f(x),
o el precio con descuento que pagaría Juan en la
librería "Nuevo mundo" por un libro de 18 dólares,
es igual a 18 * 0.5 = 9. Juan tendría que pagar
9 dólares por un libro de 18 dólares, y por un
libro de 20 dólares: 20 * 0.5 = 10. Calculemos el
precio con descuento para un libro de 18 dólares
en la librería "La cultura". En este caso, el
precio con descuento será de 18 * 0.75, que es
igual a 13.5 dólares. Para un libro de 20 dólares
en esta librería, el precio con descuento sería de
20 * 0.75, que es igual a 15. Podemos ver en las
dos librerías que los descuentos son asignados
en la misma proporción, es decir, si el precio
es el doble el descuento es el doble también,
si el precio es la mitad el descuento es la
mitad también. Comprobémoslo. Digamos que k = 2 y
x = 20, y así podemos comprobar que f(kx) = kf(x)
para la librería "Nuevo mundo": f(2*20) = 2f(20),
f(40) = 2 *10; f(40) en la librería "Nuevo mundo"
es igual a 20, y 20 es igual a 20. Hagamos este
mismo ejercicio para la librería "La cultura":
k = 2 y x = 20. Comprobemos que g(kx) = kg(x),
g(2*20) = 2g(20), g(40) = 2*15, g(40) en la
librería "La cultura" es igual 30, y 2 * 15 = 30.
Por último, vamos a comprobar gráficamente las
políticas de descuento de ambas librerías con los
datos que tenemos en nuestras tablas. En primer
lugar graficaremos los valores de la función de
la librería "Nuevo mundo": f(x) = 0.5x. En el eje
X tenemos los valores de x que corresponden a los
precios de los libros sin descuento y en el eje
Y tenemos el valor de la función lineal, que es
igual al precio con descuento de los libros.
En nuestra tabla tenemos que x = 8 y f(x) = 4,
así que ese punto está aquí; luego x = 40 y f(x)
= 20. Enseguida tenemos que x = 18 y f(x) = 9
y, por último, x = 20 y f(x) = 10. Si unimos los
puntos, vemos que corresponden a una línea recta,
por lo que comprobamos que ésta es una función
lineal. Ahora grafiquemos los valores de la
función de la librería "La cultura": g(x) = 0.75
x. Para empezar, tenemos que x = 16 y g(x) = 12;
cuando x = 40, g(x) = 30; cuando x = 18,
g(x) = 13.5, y finalmente x = 20 y g(x) = 15.
Las gráficas de estas funciones se obtienen
asignando valores reales para x. En este
caso los valores de x fueron los precios de los
libros sin descuento y de esta manera obtenemos
líneas rectas. En estas gráficas podemos apreciar
las políticas de descuento de ambas librerías.